it all started with a social media post
back in october 2019 which quickly went
viral
colleen rooney revealed her sting
operation to smoke out someone she said
was responsible for leaking false
stories about her private life to the
press
things including a visit to a gender
selection clinic in mexico and a flooded
basement in her new mansion she said she
planted these fake stories on her
personal instagram account and altered
the privacy settings to make them
visible to just her one suspect rebecca
vardy so when they ended up headlining
in the sun she could pin down the leak
vardy strenuously denied the accusations
and responded with her own lengthy post
saying colleen rooney should have called
her the internet quickly christened
rooney wagatha christie in a nod to the
world famous british crime novelist
agatha christie
[Music]
so rebecca vardy decided to sue colleen
rooney for libel saying she suffered
very serious harm to her reputation
following the allegation that she was
the leak
rooney defended the claim on the basis
of truth and said that it was in the
public interest the private lives of
many connected to the pair were dragged
into proceedings including vardy's
previous relationship with peter andre
detailed in court i had said this
about
her anatomy or a man said something
about a woman's anatomy
that would be outraged wayne rooney gave
evidence admitting he knew nothing about
the so-called sting or leaks until he
read his wife's instagram post just like
the rest of us
the court heard about an alleged awkward
conversation at euro 2016 between rooney
and vardy's husbands ex-england star
wayne rooney and leicester city striker
jamie vardy where wayne said he'd been
asked by the then england manager to ask
his teammate's wife to calm down
vardy's agent caroline watt who was
named in court as being a potential
source of some of the leaks was not at
the hearing highlighting her absence
rooney's lawyer said holding the trial
without ms what was like hamlet without
the prince of denmark there were also a
series of unfortunate incidents
including a broken laptop forgotten
passwords and lost data when a mobile
phone belonging to ms watt fell
overboard ending up at the bottom of the
north sea this led rooney's team to
accuse vadi of a deliberate and
calculated campaign to destroy evidence
something vardy's team denied
[Music]
basically colleen rooney won rebecca
vardy was found to have not been
truthful about events and the judge
found against her saying it was likely
her agent at the time undertook the
direct act of passing the information to
the sun
and here's the key bit from the judge
the evidence clearly shows in my view
that mus vardy knew of and condoned this
behavior actively engaging in it
colleen posted on instagram after the
verdict saying although i bear mrs vardy
no ill will today's judgment makes clear
that i was right about what i said on my
instagram post
rebecca vardy has spoken about the
trolling she's received since the
allegations began and both women
appealed for the hate messages to end
damages aside an eye-watering amount of
money has been spent on legal fees by
both sides estimated to run into
millions it's money that even colleen
rooney admitted in her witness statement
could have been better spent elsewhere
it's interesting to consider the bigger
picture too this case has blown open the
world of celebrities selling stories to
newspapers and could influence celebrity
journalism going forward
and when it comes to how private
information is shared on social media
it's not just the rich and famous who
should take note on what level of
privacy can really be expected by people
on social platforms and exactly what
kind of posts could potentially be
libelous and end up landing you in court